- The people I look up
to always say I'm wrong.
So I've never looked for
affirmation from anybody.
I don't need a co-sign.
I need a co-sign for--
(deep bass music)
(cheers)
You got your perspective.
(audience cheers)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(light chill beats)
You, 25 years ago had to get lucky as fuck
that seven different people
thought you were good enough.
Signed, distributed, get
on TRL, fucking this.
All these gatekeepers.
And then you have to prey like hell
that the right song was picked.
Not even by you and your team,
by some fucking executive
that's toned up to the reality.
And then if that song didn't pop,
your career was over.
Now, you make good fucking music,
you put it on SoundCloud,
Spotify, YouTube and Instagram.
And the fucking market decides.
It's the greatest era to
be a musician of all time.
The downside is, you put out shit
and people fucking shit on you.
And people have soft feelings.
And are insecure.
And they wanna be called
stupid, corny, ugly, not good.
And they give up because they
value other people's opinions
over their own ambition.
And that's why all my shit on Instagram,
if you look real carefully
under the facade of my energy
or whatever the fuck I'm saying.
I'm just trying to get people
to build their own self esteem.
Doesn't matter what XXL
or World Star
or 5000 comments,
or the 17 biggest memes in the game say.
- Mhmm
- It's been my biggest
advantage of my whole career.
Nobody, I've been very innovative.
Like, in what I've done.
Like, early to internet, early to social.
Early like, so everybody
says I'm wrong all the time.
The people I look up to
always say I'm wrong.
So I've never looked for
affirmation from anybody.
- Nah Really.
- I don't need a co-sign.
I need a co-sign from the people
that are consuming my shit.
It feels nice when Drake puts
your music in his Instagram story.
It doesn't hurt.
But it's the end consumer.
Why have you continued to grime
even though you went out five years ago
and you're starting to
have your real moment now.
Like, why?
'Cause you had no other alternative,
like what was in your head?
- Well, I feel like I still
ain't got to the point,
personally what I feel,
put all my all into it.
Like I--
- When you feel done.
- Yeah like, this next
album I'm gonna work on
I feel like I'm gonna put my all into it.
A lot of the other stuff--
- Why? 'Cause you taste
blood in the water?
- Just, not even that.
It's just like a lot of these projects,
like you said, the
industry get ahold of it.
You don't have your opinion on it,
they picking the songs,
they doing, you know?
- Yeah.
- And I just feel like over
the years I was letting them do it
because I never been sad
before so I was like,
maybe they know what
they're talking about.
- I respect that.
- Is Lady Gaga at this label?
Is Mariah Carey--
- Yeah you see all the golden
records when you walk in
and you're like alright.
- Yeah, so I'm like if
y'all know what y'all
had to take my stuff to
the next level then--
- Show me.
- Even though I was
already on an up and up.
I think my mistake was like,
handing my career over completely
to these people and trusting them.
'Cause like you said,
it's a hit or a miss.
They might think they know
what they're talking about
but if it don't work then it's like uh oh.
Where the next artist at?
You know?
So--
- 100%
- Over the years I just
been like watching and--
- When they hit, it was there doing.
When you miss, it's your fault.
- Yes, exactly.
(laughs)
- I know.
- That's why I started being like,
let me get involved
because y'all doing stuff
and I, it looked wrong
but when it is wrong
they gonna say it's me, like you just did.
So now I'm kinda like real
hands on with my project
and I really wanna do it my way.
And put my all into it
and in the end if it hit the ground,
then it's like I--
- You died in your fucking soil.
- Yeah, it was me.
Not 'cause I gave it to
everybody else, you know?
- Accountability, good for you.
- Yeah.
(light chill beats)
- It is deeply my opinion that if that
the amount that far too many people
in their 20s and 30s maximize
their down payment on a home, right?
Leaving them with no liquid
to be able to do things with them.
And if they are like me,
like I said, I, right?
And are entrepreneurial and on the offense
that they are better uses of their dollars
than buying home because in
renting a home or an apartment
they would take that too, you know,
theoretically that 2, 300,000
that they're putting
down on a down payment
and they're putting it work
when they're in their business,
building their brand through their ads
or investing in the stock market.
- [Man] I'm a prime example real quick.
So I decided after I sold
my last house, to rent.
And invest in a beverage company and--
(laughs)
I'm crushing it right now.
But that's my personal opinion,
my business opinion is that
if it's done the right way,
home ownership will always
be a great investment.
- Yes, but this is not a debate
if it's a great investment,
it's a debate of, instead
of looking backwards
of how it's been over the last 70 years.
Taking into account what the
20 year old of America are thinking today.
So, if you're Sally in rural Iowa.
And you're putting down 20,000, right?
On a $100,000 home and
you got my psychology,
I'm fascinated based
on, back to your point,
it doesn't have to be
that big of a down payment
when the down payments are smaller,
the multipliers are smaller too.
So her $100,00 home,
ten years later,
I'm fascinated by what happens
if she pays rent instead
and has that 16,000 to go to work.
That's all.
Hey guys, thank you so much for watching
my video on YouTube.
I wanted to jump in here at the end
because I'm working on
a ridiculously important
project for me.
And I have a funny feeling you could help.
If you drink wine at all,
or know anybody that drinks wine at all.
Please go to empathywines.com right now
and sign up for a subscription.
Whether it's a three pack,
whether it's a six pack,
or whether it's a whole
case of each for the year.
If you drink 36 bottles of wine a year,
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year,
please sign up for Club Empathy.
This project means the world to me.
I could really use your support.
(light chill music)